Asylum Seekers like Dennis arapi are now
squarely in the sights of the government
Dennis is from Albania and crossed the
channel by small boat in July according
to the Prime Minister Dennis is now
facing the prospect of a fast-track
return to his country of birth
I'm feeling very sad to be honest do you
think the policy will deter albanians
from trying to cross the channel in
small boats they all know now that it
won't be easy and almost nothing will be
done when they reach here
but still they think that living
illegally living hidden maybe it will
work out for them
so people will still try to cross the
channel I think that people will still
try to cross the tunnel they will find
every alternative way maybe
to be here on their own terms and live
illegally yeah
the government claims too many albanians
are exploiting the Asylum system by
claiming to be victims of human
trafficking promises to raise the
threshold of proof have been criticized
by human rights groups the first Target
of Albanian trafficking games of
Albanian citizens and they those people
cannot always rely upon the state to
provide the protection they need so all
you're doing is when you say oh it's a
safe country well it's not it's
obviously not safe for many people
Hotel accommodation for Asylum Seekers
is costing taxpayers 5.6 million pounds
a day last year just four percent of
claims were processed
this latest strategy to mend the broken
migration system comes after attempts to
send Asylum Seekers to Rwanda stalled
when a government plane was prevented
from taking off in the summer
NASA Abdullahi was on board that flight
canceled at the very last minute NASA is
from Iran and crossed the channel by
small boat in May he's one of over 140
000 Asylum Seekers waiting for a
decision on their claim
Iran
um
the government is under enormous
pressure to crack down on Small Boat
Crossings at the end of a year which has
seen legal net migration reach record
levels Lisa Holland Sky News